the reason they're calling it a fever is
perhaps because north korea doesn't have
the testing capacity of other countries
we've seen that over the pandemic
they've only conducted around 60 000
tests so when they say
350 000 people have presented with fever
since late april it seems the system
perhaps cannot keep up with it in terms
of diagnosing kobe we do know the
situation is very very serious indeed
first of all just the fact we're hearing
about it on korean state media it's not
the most transparent of places but when
they're coming out and saying this you
can be sure it is a pretty bad situation
the second sign is that kim jong-un has
been pictured at the helm of this we've
seen images of him uh addressing work
meetings of the poly bureau going to the
epidemic prevention center and his
comments in state media saying that
pyongyang was now the capital of this
outbreak and been revealed to be a
vulnerable point and he called on uh the
development of treatments at a lightning
pace so this is very serious indeed
north korea doesn't have a vaccination
program in fact it refused vaccines when
it was offered them by kovacs the
vaccine sharing initiative and china
three million vaccines rejected in
september they told them to give them to
media countries north korea may now be
the one in great in dire need really and
we could be looking at one of the worst
covered catastrophes of the pandemic so
far